I'll but running this late outside all
right ah
all right claw grin cuz I built the
pyramids off away everyone just walk
away
attack the clone I know and that's
pretty close to clickbait to get attack
of the clones
I guess that is okay Return of the Jedi
no wait the Empire Strikes Back
your quick waiting I'm a pirate Strikes
Back would be kissing prank gone sexual
Nick's doing this weird look over there
it's actually you're very quiet you have
to clean that up
yeah close it close it close it that's
not a lot it David blink fan as a
punishment you relegated to the box for
another 15 minutes
good fog them up in there so you know
how there's teflon tape on the platform
the teflon tape is like a Teflon pan you
know put that down you put your print on
top and it won't stick to it however if
your print won't stick to it how do you
print it what I've been printing with
though has been that teflon tape with
its residue basically building up from
previous prints so this morning I ended
up ripping the tape on accident when
taking a print off that was just like
I'll screw it so I put a nice clean new
tape down I basically put it on as light
as possible
printed pretty nicely
okay thank you go dear puddle this was a
lie we found out what happens when you
put someone in there we are starting a
new tradition here and this is the first
of hopefully many when ever release a
corridor digital video we're going to
sit down and we're going to read and
react to the comments live on the video
with the entire world turn to Lego if
you touch the ground I'm not actually
dead Johnny Boz school of jokes the tape
doesn't turn into Legos because it's
only touching the sides in the back of
the fingers Ren worked just cute little
butt off on this Eddy looky pancakes as
am i spooky or nah still no 60fps dude
okay guys what happened the tracking
this video is horrendous the 3d layer
was so badly composite and was shacking
around use a mocha for ayyy I guess it's
goodbye suggest upgrading your graphics
card and coupling the mocha with A's 3d
tracker if you can't disguise any better
it's but time consuming ideas will be to
recreate this set in the 3d software you
are using Maya I'm guessing due to the
oh so familiar part of the dynamics
shutter noise I've been noticing lack of
quality in work recently and maybe due
to the pressure of creating freaking
videos just hire more guys or spread
your videos apart here's all the time
black quality's more nose plier bit rate
you actually do appreciate your critique
but here's here's the here's the hard
truth guys 99% of people on the internet
don't care if you're tracking isn't very
good yeah and this is a new school of
dungeon gray really dungeon Greg do you
probably all done with that yeah this is
so much plastic yep this is pre done in
right here I'm so obviously I play a lot
D&D if you watch to note more statues
more gravestones
I got enough coffins I don't need not
more coffins but then I also got this
new type of statue that's super necro I
was like you know what Spencer I'm going
to print like six giant pieces in here
and it all worked and on the hour every
hour I'm going over there hitting print
and literally you imagine like an
infinite money machine that's what it
feels like except fruits for D&D pieces
so each time every like two-three hours
I go over there I hit print and just go
Boosh and just shoots out D&D chunks and
like I have
gosh damn it broke it all right
literally you know or you can no longer
touch any of these pieces there's so
many we want to shoot a Minecraft WWE
video and are lined up with the sensor
now so there you go now in the star war
aren't ship Enterprise Star Wars